[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh hi everyone
what's up welcome uh
i was hoping to stream this for a lot
longer but i had some major like issues
with my monitor
that i just had to fix so i'm gonna play
about half an hour of
uh crash bandicoot 4 this is the new
crash bandicoot for anyone who's not
aware
um full disclosure if you're new and you
aren't familiar with me
i am the the single video game genre
that i am the worst at
is a platformer truly terrible
at crash bandicoot and mario maker
despite having played
a lot of platformers in my time it's
just awful
um so while i actually do generally play
crash in retro when i play it i'm gonna
play modern
for you guys uh so that you don't have
to suffer through me not getting through
levels
uh because i'm bad at crash it's a real
thing
but yeah this game comes out i don't
know this week next week i think next
week
and uh i have already played a little
bit of it it's very pretty ooh let me
change my sound settings
please don't break monitor i swear to
god please
yep beautiful
that's very cute i didn't see the
cutscenes when i first played so now i
get to see these
they might come out tomorrow i don't
even know
face it entropy it's going to fail
again at least i
attempt to free us from this prison i
won't sit idly by and listen to your
inane
ramblings for another decade
it's very cute that's all i'm saying i
just think it's cute
also um very similar vibes to ratchet
and clank which i find a little bit
funny
believe him he served his purpose
that's a lot of laughter too much
all right
i'm going to crash i fear it pretends an
event of reality shattering proportions
i feel it emanating from cancer being
that i've most recently played a lot of
the insane trilogy
insane collection or is it trilogy i
think it is trilogy aku aku being voiced
is uh
fully voiced is alarming to me i feel
like i'm not used to this
all right it's crash bandicoot everyone
you know it you've seen it
he does the thing he get the fruit he
spin
i can actually be more chill the first
time i played this it was for a fun
house video where we were very
intentionally
trying to speedrun so this time you know
what i'm just gonna break my boxes get
my fruit
it's not a big deal i like that that the
show hud thing is
optional um have i played mind over
mutants i have not
uh i think this game is really pretty it
certainly feels like virtually exactly
the same as the insane trilogy
um so i just
ca but can i just break my boxes without
[ __ ] with you i can't right
yeah let's go
okay cool i'm just trying to get all the
boxes i'm trying to have a sweet chill
time
as my bandicoot self i'm in no rush
whatsoever to get anything done at all
crap
ooga off indeed how's the slide jump i
don't know that i have that unlocked yet
oh that's cool
um i will say like the thing that i've
liked about this this so
the most so far of the the time that i
did actually play um obviously this is
starting from the start of the game i
don't know how far we'll get when i only
have a small amount of time
um the boss fights are really cool i've
always liked the boss fights in crash
love that kangaroo but uh i felt like
they were extra creative this time
around
is my hot take [ __ ] off spiders
double jump
i will take boxes
that looks evil there might be something
wrong with that i don't know what's
going on
uh i'm playing this on xbox one
um i think i requested a pc code that
full disclosure activation gave me
access to this
um but yeah activision doesn't tend to
do pc codes
so we got uh xbox one for fun house
gameplay purposes because
everyone has an xbox and not everyone
has a playstation
at least that's the case for jacob i
know that's why
he doesn't have a
playstation so we tend to make sure that
um
these [ __ ] guys so rude
uh nope you don't no you don't
that's your slide
oh convenient that was great
anyway i forgot what i was saying that's
the problem with playing video games i
don't know how people do this you know
how do you do this for a living it
doesn't make sense you're talking you
play a video game at the same time very
difficult stuff
hello
good day bonus level i think i will
what am i supposed to do about that okay
i see okay oh okay that's actually
super easy if i time it right alana
doing just fine doing just fine great
killing it
beautiful work
oh i got an achievement thank you i'd
love to see it
i uh still [ __ ] hate these spiders
but yeah i also like think there's a
cool level variety not that i feel like
that's
tremendously different to any other
crash but i'm happy to be playing this
game
i have every intention of finishing it
um after i finish the insane trilogy
that's kind of the thing about oh [ __ ]
oh i didn't expect that
for whatever reason
all right bud calm down um i play these
games real slow
rather than playing them in one sitting
i don't care about you tnt you're not a
problem for me and then i just jump over
here
we got it we got it we got it we got it
i'm also just gonna say with all of my
time having played the insane trilogy
you guys
i think i'm getting better at crash
still not good not good at platforming
it's never going to be a thing that i'm
great at uh
[ __ ] off bro that was that was rude as
hell dude
tnt's count towards boxes i didn't
realize that
that means i i've i've missed so many
easy boxes i didn't have to do any of
this
that's obama
um wasn't i just saying that i know he's
gonna do it again
you know the timing you idiot that's not
even a platforming problem that's just
me being like
yes this will work perfectly
i disappoint myself
when we played this for fun house i
think john smith was like oh honey
you're so mean to yourself i was like
yeah
that's what i uh that's what i like when
i [ __ ] up at a video game just throw it
again bro here we go here we go
second [ __ ]
hmm
yeah sometimes you just gotta um hate
yourself a little bit
uh i don't actually encourage anyone to
to behave that way
but um you know where i'm concerned
sometimes just can't be helped
do i want to go that looks like a path
doesn't it
i'm not going to be tempted by it
i keep forgetting i have double jump
because it's new
how i really it's going to be all tnt
that i missed i could have done that
whole thing
i could have done that whole thing
bummer
so close bro so close all right let's
keep going
it's not a problem you know that's just
the first level it's cool i could go
back and do it at any point in time
thoughts on minecraft steve getting
confirmed for smash bros ultimate look
um i was gonna do like a reaction to
that
but
like i think it's cool but steve is not
the character that i wanted to be in
smash you know so i'm like
it's fine it's whatever do i play video
games all day and still stay in great
shape
fun fact i spend an hour
every day on most days i'm gonna be
honest i don't do it every day
um playing vr games that make me sweat
i uh i work out and beyond
it's great i thoroughly enjoy it i
highly recommend supernatural
a bit expensive uh of a subscription
service
but it's really good makes me a very
sweaty
so now i gotta just jump on him right
no damn it
that was dumb didn't need to happen
keep on swinging crash bandicoot
oh it's gone anyway all right this is
too many
but we'll do our best out here
son of a [ __ ]
how are they all so bad across the board
everything's been fine until now this is
all just terrible
all right take you out wait for the rope
to swing properly
there we go okay gonna be fine
this [ __ ] can't play crash bandicoot i
swear to god
definitely one of the first console
games i ever remember playing too
um i've been playing games since i was
like four
but i still uh
okay does it swing if i go back down you
got physics you got physics fam
okay you go [ __ ] i'm panicked oh when i
get nervous things get bad it's fine i
made it
beautiful i haven't missed any now have
i
i don't think i have i think i'm doing
okay
whip don't swing at me again bro
and then we just wait and we flip you
come over here
whoop
okay i like the uh
the swamps between the 2ds and the 3ds
as well
i think it's quite
and neat this is the first thing that
it's again doing like ratchet this is
the introduction to the
between worlds business but um as we get
a little bit further we'll see if it
happens here
you start to be able to control when
things phase in and out which is pretty
fun
i think it's like super cute
hang on what
while holding b
oh that feels uh awful
but uh we did it you know
okay let me get rid of that and just
sort of walk over here
what was my first jrpg
i didn't realize there were all those
boxes up there
i [ __ ] that up bro i [ __ ] that up
that's a huge bummer oh well whatever
um i don't know don't remember
i've obviously been playing pokemon
since i was very very very young
um
but i certainly remember final fantasy
vi
i um watched someone else play it
actually rather than playing it myself
because i would have been
very young what is that um
and thought it was incredible but he
wouldn't let me play it
all right
i got greedy these kind of these kind of
plays aren't for you a lot of peers
i'm still gonna do it
but i even make myself nervous
i know i shouldn't i'm not built for
this
but you sometimes you just can't help it
we'll just take it nice and slow you
know
oh of course you [ __ ] idiot you have
to jump on top of it you know that
take it nice and slow she rushes the
thing that will immediately kill her
aye aye
levels on this game are super creative i
feel like they are
um yeah i'm happy with it it's fun and
it it definitely
feels like old i shouldn't have done
that so i hadn't even done it yet and i
was like you've made a mistake
um it feels like old crash
so like still super nostalgic feels like
it could have existed
forever ago but obviously modern [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um some some modern graphics
i i think the boss fights are a bit more
involved even not necessarily um i'm
definitely happy with it though
it's the tnt that i have beef with fam
i'm gonna i'm gonna give up i'm giving
up
i can do this in my own time i won't
make you guys watch this
that's just mean and i can't stream for
very long how long we've been streaming
cool
okay so 10 minutes before i have a
meeting
goddamn tnt
what oh i didn't know that was a thing
that could happen
it uh it grew when i was inside of it
nice nice nice nice nice
i wanted to i just did that that's that
was just me
we just should i maybe just not even go
for any of them
i'm getting worse so let's just [ __ ]
get out of here shall we
no i guess we're not getting out of here
slow down alana
hey at least i know what i'm bad at and
i own it you know
not pretending to be good at it bad at
timing i have bad reflexes and my depth
perception is off
it's so cute though
hello it's midna
i really like the way they animate
crouch too i think it's really cute
all right buddy get your fruits
i i've always loved these ones even
since i was a
a wee lass i've always liked the running
toward perspective that they haven't
crashed i don't know why
something about it my finger is slipping
though
there's a lot of shock waves you got
there bro damn okay
oh my god my thing is absolutely
slipping i have to keep readjusting it
well i didn't deserve to be successful
at that but we did it
no uh i had time for that but it's fine
not great on that one not great but
uh he still break dances so you know
we'll take it
13 that's excellent excellent excellent
what are you doing here okay don't have
a lot of time
how on twitch at youtube at the same
time um
free stream it's pretty great
is quantum rift since i got
an android phone for uh between
dimensions
sex cloud yes and i don't know how to
use it
it just keeps reminding me of things and
i get confused i'm like why did you make
a noise
and where are you even monumentally
stupid
unknowingly paved the way for our
brighton indeed
once my rich generator is complete
dominion over all of time and space will
be within our
yes engine embryo you had some little
projects you wanted to tell me about
yesterday
[Music]
am i enjoying it so far yeah definitely
yeah i like it
pacing your steps by my calculations our
enemies are already moving against us
and we will prevail
ooh nice eyeliner
alright so this is like the wild map
that we've now unlocked again pretty
standard crash stuff
when it unlocks come on buddy come up
buddy
there you go we're all very proud of you
excellent so that's where i was
uh this is like a junkyard world yeah
it's pretty neat i think it's cool
pow let's go
what inspired the rift trend in crash
and ratchet it is weird that it's
happening at the same time and
very similarly too they're both like
purple rifts
very uh
specific looking
i think that cool creative ideas though
all right so we need the other masks to
close the rifts
correct that's what's up now my brother
econo is around here somewhere
all right
behold the aforementioned butts don't
worry did he say that brothers
i have some questions
some kind of european accent yeah so
this is like mad max [ __ ] including the
boss fight in this level is very mad max
so here you go see see what's happening
here they sort of just poof in and out
actually i'm gonna test if i die no just
break some that's neat
i wonder what i would do about those
boxes
an interesting puzzle
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you can get real speedy on that um
with some practice i feel like that uh
that'll be a lot of fun
oh my gosh that wasn't even a checkpoint
i was just trying to get fancy with it
why have i done that alana you know you
can't get fancy with it you're bad at
crash bandicoot we've established this
it is not something that you have any
skill at don't worry about it it's fine
you're just trying to show the people
the level variety
just keep going bro look it's a little
parasect
checkpoint love it okay
i expected something to there we go
there it is jump out of the
ground what's up with you
cool sand shock oh my gosh she has like
a a metal lulla
jaw oh i love you
big fan of sharks
that's fine right it's interdimensional
yeah you don't have to worry about any
of
that
oops press the wrong button i press y
instead of x
that was stupid
oh there's two damn it
i always know when i've made the mistake
before the mistake has even happened
all right bud come on it's two of you
two jumps look how cool crash looks in
his is like
an interdimensional suit too what a cool
guy
that one's only got one all right
what it's because i didn't press y
yes the same problem we had the the
first time
where we did the exact same thing
it's okay everything's gonna be fine
and again genuinely people i think i've
gotten better at crash bandicoot
um so now i'm okay
it was worse this is one of those baas
yeah oh i could have gone up there
that's all right okay we can't we gotta
watch out for the nitro
yeah i enjoy the the uh
inter-dimensional stuff i think it's fun
it's cute it's fun i like it
didn't work at all it's okay
let's just keep going i wish this was
faster and we'll say that much
these slidey bits
who put spikes there
okay i feel like my eyes aren't even
really registering what's happening
i'm completely glossed over all of it
a and b is slam on this you say
cool
oops should have expected it
should
i don't need any of it anyway though you
know all right
don't fall off just stay
alive is the current goal i can go back
and do this on my own time
you people don't have to watch me suffer
you know
oh you can swing that's cute
very cute um i have already played this
level but i guess when we were doing the
speedrun thing i wasn't even reading i
was just like let's keep going
little mad max guys very cute i feel
like i say the word cute too much but
would you look at it could you see it
all right uh people in my twitch talking
about me not being partnered again
look i've thought about it truth is um i
don't stream to make money
you know it's not my job so
why um
just a thing that i do for fun sometimes
um
i just uh i just don't feel i need to i
know it means you can get like cooler
modes and i have thought about doing it
more recently
because i like the idea of having ah
two different places for different types
of content
rather than streaming on youtube and
then i would have the edits on youtube
like i've been thinking about it
but uh no terribly strong motivation too
i'm not a streamer you know oh okay okay
okay
cool cool cool
we're just getting started how do you
destroy the naturocrates without dying i
wonder
because they explode on touch also how
am i doing on time i gotta go it's
time for a meeting i unfortunately
yeah i was planning to stream for way
longer but that didn't work out because
um
my monitor was [ __ ] up so i had to
fix that first so sorry everyone
oh there's a box at the end good to know
anyway really like the game so far
here is an example of me playing it uh
as a person who is bad at it
just a little sneak peek for you guys to
check out a little bit of what's going
on how it looks how similar it is to
the crash that you already know so um
yeah thanks for joining me you guys i'll
see you all later